this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
everybody welcome back to the channel
it's at this time when I get to look
back and think about what really Rose to
the top what was the cream of the crop
what were the best books I read in 2022
you know I read some stinkers
um it happens that's live didn't read as
much as one or two this year
unfortunately you know I graduated
college we moved to a different state by
the way uh I set up a P.O box I know
people have been asking me about that so
it's on the about thing it's in the
description and then in the future maybe
we'll be doing a you know a mail opening
kind of videos we'll see I don't know
you know 2023 is the year for
experimentation all right on to the
books five Decembers this Edgar
award-winning novel
um came out in 2021 I believe it looks
old but it's not just published by hard
case crime this is basically a period
piece it's it's although it is written
like um hard-boiled Noir beautiful
evocative writing style that's very
crisp no excess no fat just very lean I
I love this style of writing and not
everyone can pull it off well it's it's
tough but you know James does it James
Kestrel is a pseudonym for a writer
called Jonathan Moore who I'm reading
some of his other books right now so
it's done me it starts off about a a cop
who works in Hawaii and he's he's on a
brutal murder case it just happens to be
1941 certain stuff happened in Hawaii
you know in 1941 in December
specifically a lot of the intimate like
detective crime stuff in there with the
huge massive canvas of world history
tons of twists I mean I've thought
already about rereading this even though
I read it not too long ago it just not
only does it have that like thrilling
intensity and excitement but it has that
emotional punch longing of sadness of
time passing people by so I've talked
about this in other videos do yourself a
favor buy this book pick it up read five
Decembers the next book I want to talk
about I'm kind of surprised to include
on this list because I didn't think I
would you know I I was looking over the
stuff I read throughout the year and I
thought you know what actually that does
hold up connected with it in a weird way
and that book is Hitman by Lawrence
Block Lawrence block is in the great
tradition of you know hard-boiled you
know crime fiction just is just a
fantastic writer and this book is really
deceptively funny it's it's pretty
hilarious to be warned however that it
does have the feeling more or less like
a collection of short stories although
they are interlinked and there is an
overarching story throughout this novel
but uh the book follows Keller who is a
Hitman and he just kind of has his life
going on is just like a normal guy who
lives in New York City but just happens
to kill people and balancing those two
worlds and looking at those two worlds
is really funny and um dark never not
interesting it's always interesting
Lawrence block has these great
observations and is so the humor is very
dry it's a really great book and you
know I think that I don't know if this
is true but I've heard that it was a big
influence on the show Barry which makes
a ton of sense what does it mean to kill
people and also kind of the banality of
evil Keller is immensely likable despite
what he he does even more interesting
than the crimes is at some point in the
book Keller becomes so interested in
stamp collecting that it just consumes
his life it's just it's just like great
and all these little observations about
these cities in America and every it's
just stuck with me and I'm reading the
the sequel so you know no Fantasy on
this list I didn't read much fantasy at
all this year I crime crime was on my
mind for some reason uh anyhow this is
not a crime novel but it is a good one
and it's short by the the man himself uh
Cormac McCarthy's the road so many
people have read this I mean if it's
it's Oprah Oprah's Book Club probably
McCarthy's most popular book but I read
it this year for the disturbing books
challenge I was surprised at how
emotionally impactful this was so many
people talk about how depressing this
book is it is about in a
post-apocalyptic situation but we're
basically following a father and son as
they try to survive uh the world has
basically ended everything's just ash
and there's like you know nomadic tribes
of people running around killing each
other and they're just trying to survive
and there's no hope is about the love
that the father and son have for each
other and it's this nothing in
McCarthy's novels I I've ever seen
approaches this kind of like spiritual
like intensity I wouldn't say it's like
a a religious book there's not nothing
specifically spiritual about it but this
drive and this love deep down that it's
like a book that has faith in something
you know and by the final few pages I
mean the whole book you know hinges on
it's it's prose on its style and how it
you know McCarthy can can gather up this
momentum of just like great physical
detail of just like immersing you into
the The Narrative and then hit you with
this like archaic language and this kind
of almost like jarring poetic turn of
phrase that's hard to swallow a little
bit but it hits you nonetheless and then
at the end I was just swept up in it I
was so moved I was tearing up it was
fantastic I mean if you haven't read it
read the road it's it's out it's it's
it's in theaters the fact that a year
ago I was doing the 2021 list that was
my first skillshare sponsorship I
believe they've stuck with me and I've
had a great relationship with Scotia I
love skillshare and the ad is starting
right now skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creators explore
new skills deepen existing passions and
get lost in creativity with skillshare I
love skillshare I love using it I mean
that's one of the perks of getting to uh
you know do sponsored ad reads for that
I I gravitate towards like writing stuff
and creativity and filmmaking that sort
of stuff but there are two classes that
I want to recommend the writer's toolkit
six steps to a successful writing habit
by Simon van boy uh is a fantastic
course about making uh a writing habit
building on that and finding your Rhythm
and I I found that immensely useful to
me and a recent one I found which is
from uh Nathaniel Drew who is uh who's a
YouTuber I really liked I've watched a
lot of his videos and uh the fact that
he was uh doing this on skillshare uh
made me happy it's also a great course
it's called creativity Unleashed
discover hone and share your voice
online how someone who is being creative
online I was like yeah show me the good
stuff I oh that sounded that came off
weird but honestly there's there's good
advice in there and I I really enjoyed
watching it you can view it in bite size
videos or watch the full course it's
curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused skillshare now offers
classes in Spanish French Portuguese and
German the first thousand people to
click on the link in the description get
skillshare for free for one month check
it out all right now back to the list
the next book is another crime novel and
it was written in the 60s by an author
who I had never read before and it just
came as a godsend to me you I was you
know in a reading drought and I was
looking for something really good it is
called the Expendable Man by Dorothy B
Hughes Dorothy B Hughes wrote uh quite a
few novels and a couple of them were
turned into the movies uh Classic Movies
ride the pink horse in a lonely place
that's I'm going to read that next in a
lonely place this book tackles big
issues especially the issues of you know
race racism and how horribly racist the
times were especially you know this is
about a student he was UCLA and he's a
medical student he's trying to avoid
these false charges now the book is very
procedural and and follows through on
this kind of like slow-motion car crash
of just this guy trying to get out under
this pressure and in the kind of complex
situation of you know trying to get
ahead of the story trying to outwit the
cops the book is written beautifully and
has just a great sense of period detail
and for its time it was extremely uh
like there are very dated elements to
this book before its time I thought it
was really powerful and really made a
statement and I'm really glad to see
this book you know getting discovered
and pushed out getting a Resurgence and
I hope Dorothy Hughes is overall but um
God just an Incredible Book parts of it
feel very Progressive there are elements
that are quite Antiquated and um not so
great especially of involving abortion
so overall it's just like a stunning
work of fiction and in what it's trying
to do and say I think it it exceeds and
I'm I'm really happy I read it so check
it out if you want something if you want
something old that feels a little new
now my final book and I'm going to say
my favorite read of 2022 I don't think
it'll be a surprise to those who watch
these videos this surprised me quite a
bit and I don't know why I felt
compelled to read it at the time I did
but wow I'm so glad I did the book is
called Wuthering Heights Emily Bronte I
have to thank a couple channels um books
and bow for talking about this and uh
books by Lanes they're both a couple of
my favorite channels but hearing them
talk with such passion about this book
really got me eager to read it because
this I don't know why people portray
this book as being like some kind of
like romance novel it's not it's like a
horrifying book it is quite disturbing
it's not like even within the the book
it's commented on how like horrible this
relationship is and all of the
relationships are this book is about the
cycle of abuse I'm going to show you all
the darkness kind of vibe it feels very
out there and I get that there are
people who really hate it because of
that because it really kind of shows you
the Despair and may come off as
melodramatic I think part of what's so
wonderful about it is that that does
have this it contains this melodrama but
it is
within this like darker context and and
with such incredible language and Beauty
but my God is it kind of depressing and
and by the end of the near the end of
the book I was like is anything like
happy going going to happen I can go
through here and like look at some of
these models evil mean-spirited violent
brutal people but they speak like King
Lear they're like Shakespearean but
everything's observed from someone who
is grounded who can say like wow these
people are ridiculous you know it's like
it's like Shakespeare narrated by one of
the side players Gothic Gothic Gothic
really um the language doesn't feel
super I mean there are some like
Victorian novels that feel very hard to
read hard to get through but this one uh
that the pros moved right along
characters are so vibrant and clear
they're they're never caricatures
they're they're huge and bigger than
life but they also they all have their
own pathetic natures and and you feel
sorry for them you feel sympathy for
them you can even understand some of
them but they still do evil horrible
things and there are only a couple
characters who I really cared a lot
about anyways I read a lot of dark books
this year I'm realizing
um I I don't know why I mean I I just I
don't know why I read something funny
but the hot rock that I mean that could
be on this list the hot rock is a very
funny crime novel yeah let me know what
your favorite books were that you read
this year let me know if you have you
read any of these but yeah now my P.O
box is up 2023 is on I'm excited I
already read a couple of Richard Stark
novels thank you for watching talk to
you all later bye bye